a lot we got a lot to talk about not the
least of which it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger oh we could do a whole
show of this I got four pages of notes
here this this story has a timeline like
the bin Laden raid because we got some
information and there's more information
than something else came along and it
was on the grassy knoll and there was
like the magic [ __ ] bullet went
through Arnold's head at one point I
read something about the kid he fathered
having all his teeth ripped out replaced
with titanium fangs know that that
turned out to be a rumor that was true
so early in the week we found out that
warts [ __ ] fathered a child with a
member of his household staff yes and
immediately we thought all the hottest
one absolutely turns out it was 50 year
old patty Mahina on another way yeah he
announced earlier this week after
leaving the governor's office I told my
wife about this event which occurred
over a decade ago I understand and
deserved the feelings of anger and
disappointment upon my friends and
family now no excuses and I take full
responsibility for the hurt I have
caused I have apologized to Maria my
children and my family I am truly sorry
I asked that the media respect my wife
and children through this extremely
difficult time so the media has to
respect your wife
after you [ __ ] on her for a decade all
right Arnold I will honor your wishes
sir no I won't apparently this woman was
the housekeeper who worked for them for
20 years yeah she was by all accounts
obsessed with Maria Shriver wanted to be
Maria Shriver would dress in Maria's
clothing when Maria wasn't home
shots of dressing her husband as well
would put on her jewelry and go out
around town wearing her clothing and
jewelry really like single white female
yes maybe this was all an accident like
Arnold's like I love you Maria and she
looked up she's like nah hurry up caught
a mouthful quick like two and then baby
[Music]
possible according to friends she would
wait for Maria to leave the house in the
morning then crawl into the marital bed
with Arnold and [ __ ] him in the marital
bed well after Maria had just left oh
you thought the first thing I ever did
was end of days but no he was this
[ __ ] is the housekeeper
when Maria resided all going to work I
don't know what did she do anyone know
what a job was I don't I'm too worried
about my [ __ ] he's the [ __ ] yeah
enough of that this week he's the
[ __ ] he's the infidel inator he's
the housekeeper Raydor okay apparently
it sounded like he was sports coming
with the information he didn't confess
to this situation until Maria confronted
the housekeeper about it and the house
housekeeper gave it up that's how she
found out yes
and she went to Arnold said you know
it's funny I was just talking to maid
and I asked her if you [ __ ] her 10
years ago and you had a kid she said yes
Arnold anything I've been meaning to
tell you
so she said Arnold move out he said no
so she did and now she's got a divorce
lawyer and they're on their way
unbelievable [ __ ] no weird sad and
[ __ ] I wish I imagined it in my head
being more like she found out from the
maid she confronted Arnold in front of
the maid and showed in the pictures when
both she and the maid were
simultaneously pregnant
yeah and said explain this and Arnold
was just like it's not a two
that twins I can't keep track of all the
children but am i a kindergarten cop
[Applause]
Maria's gonna get my home all my money
her pockets will jingle all the way
[Applause]
because all night I've been filling
ahead for ten years
with True Lies I may have [ __ ] a maid
I don't know because I don't have Total
Recall
[Applause]
while this story was going on listener
scott tweeted is it me or does Arnold's
mistress mistress look like Cesar Romero
as the Joker here's hoping that was just
a really bad picture well let's take a
look let's throw them up on the screen I
gotta say there is a strong family
resemblance
yes ah de cochon you haven't have you
[Music]
yes the boy blunder should've used a
rubber yes yes Kevin Smith that girl
brush one for tinsel Batman
[Music]
you
[Music]